first the assassination of Iran's top
general then Iranian retaliation in the
deepening conflict between Iran and the
United States the European Union seems
caught in the middle the current crisis
deeply affects not only the region but
all of us
and the use of weapons must stop now to
give space to dialogue talks seem to be
the only feasible option here in
Brussels at the moment the European kind
of dilemma is that they of course want
to put additional pressure on Iran but
at the same time they don't want to side
too openly with the United States that's
the dilemma that the Europeans are in
this is what their politics looks like
you know how do you find the magic
formula that you know keeps you in that
position that you know satisfies both
both needs the EU is clinging on to the
2015 nuclear deal signed by EU countries
France the UK and Germany among others
the so-called jcpoa is supposed to
prevent Iran from developing nuclear
weapons in return for the lifting of UN
sanctions however US president Trump
pulled out in 2018 he since we imposed
sanctions a move met with anger in
Tehran which in response has
step-by-step reduced its own commitments
to the deal further limiting the EU s
ability to weigh in on the issue as
jcpoa was the only stake the Europeans
really had in the Iran issue that's you
know what made them important in the
Iran context and now that's out of the
window plus the situation is escalating
and they have no influence
now some hope lies in this man Mohammad
Zarif the Iranian Foreign Minister he's
been invited back to Brussels in an
attempt to bring Iranians back to the
table and negotiate a way out of the
crisis a lot more on this story DWS
chief political editor mechanic ooft nur
spoke to the head of Germany's
parliamentary Foreign Affairs Committee
that's conservative
Norbert alert can she asked him whether
Europe should continue to stick to the
Iran nuclear deal despite demands
President Trump - except that it was
dead absolutely and as long as there is
no better option to make sure that Iran
does not develop nuclear weapons I think
we should stick to that of course we
have to see and we have to face the
facts that the US has withdrawn from
this treaty and by this economically has
massively damaged the effectivity of the
agreement so we should stick to that
perhaps we should embrace his proposal
to broaden the negotiation and the
relationship to Iran not only to focus
just on the nuclear aspect but to
include further regional aspects in
order to create a broader arrangement
for regional stability I think we should
we should embrace and appreciate this
approach and I think the the role for
the Europeans to make this possible is
absolutely vital and crucial now Europe
keeps talking about broadening this Iran
nuclear deal Trump wants a new deal
which also has his name on the paper how
do you read the action of the u.s.
president right now
I read his actions in the way that he is
absolutely determined to avoid war he
thinks at the same time that he can't
afford to be seen as weak and this is
absolutely parallel to the Iranian
leadership they want to avoid war
despite the aggressions but they can't
think they can't afford to be seen as
weak so I think there is a viable
approach by the US President to
substitute the jcpoa which he has lost
all the time with a new diplomatic
approach how far this can go we have to
see but this at least is a new tune from
Washington that is not only sticking to
the policy of maximum pressure that he
has introduced the aspect of negotiation
and diplomatic approaches what will
happen to German engagement in Iraq if
the US troops have to leave
this is absolutely clear we want to stay
because we see our objective there has
not yet accomplished to really have the
victory on make sure that Isis is is
defeated in Iraq and to contribute to
the stability and unity of the country
so we want to stay there but if the
United States were forced by the Iraqi
government to leave the country because
they are deep were declared Austin as
not being welcome there then we would
also have to leave because we are
interdependent in our military presence
there and we need to have the u.s. there
as our allies and partners no but what
can head of the Foreign Affairs
Committee of the German Bundestag thank
you very much